Yeah,
I like to think of innovation as a
process.
It's a process of transforming new ideas
into tangible societal impact and so
that means that it's not enough to just
have a new idea,
but it's really important for that idea
to make an impact,
to scale,
to grow,
to touch many peoples' lives.
Certainly it can create financial
wealth,
but it also creates social wealth,
social capital,
human capital,
and so it's really important to look at
it from that whole perspective.
Right now we're in a very challenging
situation and obviously,
and everyone's wondering where the next
job's going to come from and absolutely
new jobs are going to have to come from
new businesses and new products and
those come from from new ideas,
so if you do incremental innovation,
you might grow,
have a little bit of a economic growth,
but it's the real fundamental,
groundbreaking ideas that create whole
new sectors,
whether it's the internet or
biotechnology or now green technology,
a water technology,
and there's some real needs and
challenges in the world.
Grand challenges that will also only be
solved with some serious innovation.
A lot of people think that economic
downturns time to really buckle down and
look within and uh,
you know,
there's not going to be any
opportunities.
And the reality is that during an
economic downturn,
that could be some of the biggest
opportunities for individuals,
entrepreneurs and companies.
In fact,
the majority of the Dao,
the companies in the Dow,
we're funded or were founded in an
economic downturn,
a Disney,
Cisco,
um,
Caterpillar,
a tons of companies that have really
seized an opportunity.
And part of that is because you don't
have a situation where everyone wants to
get into the game.
And,
uh,
everyone says,
oh,
it's my turn to make a buck.
And A,
they're not really serious about the
passion of their idea.
It's really the best,
uh,
only people that are really resourceful
and see a real opportunity and jump in
there probably are going to survive.
But it's a real opportunity for those
ideas to flourish.
And it's also,
in some ways it might be more
challenging to start a company,
but at the same time it can be easier
because the rents are cheap.
The talents cheap.
You don't have as much competition,
others jumping into the market,
so there's some positive sides for the
entrepreneur as well.
Universities have historically been a
huge source of innovation for the
country and in fact there was a study
that was done recently a couple of years
ago that looked at the r and d,
100,
which is the hundred most significant
innovations of the year as defined by R
and d magazine.
And what was interesting,
they looked over the last 30 or more
years of historically speaking,
and if you look at about 30 years ago,
a 20 slash 25,
30 years ago,
about 70 percent of the most significant
innovations had found their initial idea
in a private in the private sector and
industry had funded it exclusively and
now it's completely flipped.
So 70 percent our fund are founded or
developed using public funding
universities and a federal labs.
So that's an example of,
or a demonstration of something that
people have been saying for a little
while now is that you just don't have
the bell labs and Xerox,
Xerox Parks and industry to be doing
some of the really fundamental research
that's going to be creating the
breakthrough ideas of the next,
um,
of the next generation.
So universities,
um,
they,
they really form a nexus of innovation,
um,
ecosystems and they,
they're the source of the real
breakthrough ideas that we're going to
be in eating and innovation.
One thing that I'm very passionate about
and I think is really important for
people to understand is every year in
this country we spend taxpayers,
the federal government spends $50,
billion dollars a year on university
research.
And that's absolutely critical because
that's where the,
the new ideas are going to be coming
from and the real breakthroughs.
Uh,
however we spent $50,
million dollars a year on research,
but we spend almost nothing on the
programs in universities to get those
ideas out into the market.
Despite that,
we still,
there's a study by the Association of
university technology managers,
autumn,
the latest study from 2008.
They do a survey every year show that,
um,
there've been,
you know,
over 600 new products that are developed
that were developed that year and almost
600 startups have spun out of
university,
uh,
intellectual property and there's about
3,300 university spin outs that are in
business today.
And so it's,
it's despite the fact that we're not
investing in it,
it is happening,
but it's not happening at nearly the
rate.
And I've seen it with my own eyes that
there are things that are sitting on the
shelves and sitting in the labs that are
not seeing the light of day.
And I believe that it's really in large
part because of the.
There's a big gap between the university
in the market.
Well first you know,
what,
what is,
what is that gap?
And a lot of people talk about something
called the valley of death and it's
primarily seen as a funding gap.
There's some really interesting ideas in
the lab,
but just they're a little bit too far
removed from,
from the private sector is willing to
invest in it,
so we need to do a proof of concept to
show that these ideas will actually work
for specific market needs to address,
to address specific market needs.
Um,
and so that's,
that's one need.
And uh,
the angel investors,
venture capitalists are not filling that
gap and I'm not sure that it really
isn't appropriate for them to be filling
that gap because these are not ready for
it to be a startup or a product yet.
Um,
but it's also a cultural gap.
So in the university,
uh,
the,
you know,
the motivations are how do I support my
students and how do I,
um,
how do I get the next research grant,
how do I raise my reputation as the
expert in this field?
Um,
whereas in the private sector,
of course it's about revenues,
profits and,
and so,
and those are completely appropriate
motivations for the two groups.
And so in another way I like to think
about it as an academia.
Surprises are good,
but in industry not so much.
So,
uh,
it was definitely a big cultural gap and
what we're,
what,
what we don't want to do is we don't
want to try to turn academics into
business people and we certainly are not
going to get business people to try to
become academics,
but will we need to do is to help
connect them,
uh,
and help connect the two cultures and
enable them to learn about each other
and what motivates them so that they can
speak each other's language.
And so,
um,
it's,
it's really about the bridging and
about,
about teaching.
So we've had some,
um,
you know,
across the country have been some
success successes with innovation
centers and proof of concept funds and
uh,
a greater focus on tech transfer and on
entrepreneurship education.
And so I have a proposal that I wrote
with the support of many others that as
called the impact proposal.
It was at the urging of the White House
Office of Science and Technology Policy.
They said,
how can we help bridge this gap?
And the idea behind it is a,
to start with a pilot program,
a $20,000,000 pilot program where a
handful of universities would be
selected to develop these programs,
innovation programs to provide small
proof of concept grants,
50 $100,000 to faculty and students to
provide mentoring for the faculty and
the students and,
um,
provide some educational resources and
connections to the outside community and
really build ecosystems around these
centers.
And it's built on,
um,
you know,
it's worked before,
but to help build it into a best
practice that others can build on.
And ultimately,
hopefully the federal government would
see that there is a value,
incredible value that would pay back in
many,
many fold that so would be worth
investing in this process.
The PR and the,
the local capacity around the
university.
So the university's would serve as the
nexus of these innovation ecosystems.
And I think that universities are
particularly well suited to serve as
that nexus because not only are
universities creating some of the most
exciting ground breaking technologies
and ideas already.
Um,
but we're also incredibly situated with,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of alumni that
want to get involved.
We have brands,
local,
uh,
interest in the local community and
we're also really good conveners because
a,
we don't have any private interest or
any particular bias and um,
and we're also incredibly good at
educating people.
So we,
that's,
that would be,
that's a really powerful role.
And up until now universities have,
you know,
the main focus of the university is the
creation and dissemination of knowledge.
So this is it.
This is an extension of that already,
you know,
important,
very important mission to the point
where,
how do we disseminate that knowledge to
make greater societal impact?
Well,
I'm in the 2008 item survey.
Um,
they were,
they surveyed all the universities and
the assault spinouts that have been
created out of university intellectual
property and uh,
and this does not include,
to be clear either the student startups
and other startups that may be created
not based on intellectual property that
um,
the,
uh,
72 percent of startups that spin out of
universities stay local within the state
of the university.
So it has a huge economic impact and um,
it also because of that ecosystem
feeling indeed can,
and I've seen it happen when I,
when I was at mit and now that I'm at
USC to have these and promote the ideas
that are within the university in a
programmatic fashion.
It's a very,
a very successful way,
are very,
very effective way of getting alumni
involved and getting the local business
community involved within the university
and come together and then meet each
other.
So it snowballs and it just becomes much
more,
becomes a really vibrant community.
Many people have asked me whether is
this just appropriate for a elite
universities?
And I think that's absolutely not,
uh,
not the case because,
any,
any university either that does research
or has students that are,
have some sort of entrepreneurial
inclination would really be better,
would be well served to be trying to
increase that,
that type of inactivity in the case of a
smaller university that might have a
smaller research budget,
uh,
they can,
they can band together to a greater
critical mass.
So for example,
if a friend of mine who's heading up
tech transfer at Brandeis University in
Boston,
she's working with other universities in
that area to create a consortium so that
they can work together and have that,
have a much larger research base to
attract more individuals to that,
to that group so that there's definitely
opportunities for any university to
participate in this sort of activity.
Um,
the,
the reality is there have been studies
that show that the more
basic and the more groundbreaking the
research,
the more effective tech transfer and
innovation there is from the university.
So I would encourage those universities
to not give up the roots of doing some
really basic research because I think
there's a bit of a temptation to say,
oh,
well,
we only have a small research base.
Let's try to move as much of it into
applied research as possible.
And I think that that's absolutely not,
would not be the right approach if
you're really trying to make some
groundbreaking innovations.